The golden boy tried,
uh,
many years ago,
didn't they?
With reflection was in Oscar part of that.
I remember Oscar.
Donald Trump.
That's right.
Yeah.
Dot Com was a part of affliction.
That's right.
Josh Barnett sunk that ship.
Josh [inaudible] tested positive and that ship sunk,
remember?
Yeah.
And then the UFC bought it like right afterwards.
That they had some fun fights though.
That fucking Tim Silvia fate or fight was wild as shit.
Andrea at Osceola Laski Fade,
hardly get Donald Sharp and fader.
He with Tom at tent.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
Back in the day.
Sun.
Yeah.
Donald Trump and Tim Sylvia.
That's hilarious.
He was a totally different character back then.
Donald Trump was like a fun guy.
Like everybody liked him.
You won't use those at the boxing fights.
Yeah.
People liked him.
He'd get cheered on.
Now people are so fucking mad at him.
Same Guy.
They don't see him that way.
No,
they don't.
They don't,
man.
That's why he has those security around them now.
Oh yeah.
You asked too.
Yeah.
You fucked up.
Became president.
She huge mistake for anybody.
You want to enjoy your life.
Don't be fucking president.
That has,
you know,
he could disappear,
get facial surgery or something.
So of course,
once you get that booklet with all the secrets of the history,
the CFR book,
just for that,
what do you think gives you that book?
Is it the CIA,
the NSA who comes to you with the book?
Some guy with no face.
No face?
Yeah,
like a,
the the guy with the [inaudible] and the mass.
What does the watchmen,
who was that guy?
Ink Blot.
What's his name?
Shack.
Raw Shack.
That's right.
That guy.
Yeah.
He comes to you.
You come see what the phone and be.
Everything's in that book.
We all know what's in them.
Tell me,
I don't know what's in that book.
You don't know what's in that book?
What's in the book?
You think?
I'm going to say here and what the minions are people listening to get killed?
I can't see.
I seen the book,
but I can't tell.
What do you think's in the bone?
Jovi.
What do you think?
If you had to guess.
I wouldn't even want to say President Jorge,
your first day in office.
Mr Monster High Doll.
A word you like to,
uh,
would you like to go over first?
Is Elvis still alive?
What about Tupac?
Where the fuck we're super guy.
Who else?
What's going on with these Amiens bro?
They real which,
which was mind number one.
One.
Number one I want to know about aliens.
I was hoping,
this is my hope.
When all these people screaming his treats about Trump,
like I was hoping the moment he gets in,
he's going to ask about aliens because Trump's into conspiracies.
Like he used to go on the Alex Jones show all the time.
I know he's into conspiracies.
If you were going to be the president,
the first thing you'd ask is fucking aliens.
What do you got?
What's going on here with these green fellows now about what's going on with
them?
I don't know.
You live in Florida.
There's plenty of aliens down there now.
We don't go.
Oh yeah,
we got a lot of agencies,
different types of aliens.